منذ اشهر تتبادل كييف وحلفائها مع طهران
الاتهامات والنفيه حول تزويد روسيا
بمسيارات ايرانيه قتاليه تستخدمها في
الحرب احدث فصول ذلك الجدل ما اعلنته هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه شان وصول فريق اخر من
المدربين الايرانيين الى لوغانسك لتدريب
الجيش الروسي على استخدام مسيرات هجوميه
حديث تزامن مع تصريح من الخارجيه
الامريكيه عن قاعده في القرم لاطلاق
مسيرات ايرانيه من قبل روسيا في سبتمبر
الماضي كان اول اعلان اوكراني عن اسقاط
مسيره ايرانيه اطلقتها ومنذ ذلك الحين
تقول كيف انها اسقطت 80% من جميع المسيرات
الموجهه ضدها متهمه موسكو باستخدام تلك
المسيرات في ضرب منشات البنيه التحتيه
الاوكرانيه
ابرز المسيرات الايرانيه شاهد 136 التي
يتراوح سعرها بين 20 الى 50 الف دولار
وتزن 200 كلغ هناك ايضا المسيره مهاجر سته
القادره على التحليق اثنتي عشره ساعه
والبالغ مداها الفيلم
الموقف الايراني من الاتهامات الاوكرانيه
الغربيه لم يكن قاطعا نفي رسميا تقول
طهران انها بالفعل زودت موسكو بمسيارات
ولكن قبل الحرب في الوقت نفسه قال القيادي
السابق بالحرس الثوري حسين كنعان مقدم
لموقع الجزيره نت ان بلاده تنتج المسيرات
لتقليص الاعتماد على النفط ولا تهتم
بالمواقف الغربيه لكن في الثامن من فبراير
الجاري نسبت وكاله ايرنا للانباء لمستشار
بارز لوزير الاستخبارات الايرانيه دون ان
تسميه القول ان المسيرات الايرانيه تقوم
بدور حاسم في الحرب بين روسيا والغرب
لاوكرانيا بالمقابل رصيد من المسيرات
القتاليه ابرزها برقدار تي بي اثنان
التركيه القابله للتزويد بقنابل موجهه
بالليزر والقادره على التحليق بارتفاع
سبعه الاف متر بمدى يبلغ 300 كيلو متر
وبسرعه قصوى تبلغ 220 كيلومترا في الساعه
وكانت الولايات المتحده قد اعلنت تزويد
اوكرانيا بمسيارات اشهرها من طراز سويتش
بليد 600 الانتحاريه التي تزن نحو 22 كيلو
جراما ويمكنها التحليق اربعين دقيقه بمدن
يتجاوز اربعين كيلو مترا وبسرعه تزيد على
100 كم في الساعه ومع ذلك يتصاعد انزعاج
حلفاء اوكرانيا من المسيرات التي تطلقها
روسيا وتتهم ايران بتوريدها كان احدث
الداخلين على الخط وزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي الذي زار كييف الخميس واتفق مع
زلينسكي على العمل المشترك ضد ايران في
المحافل الدوليه